just about what happened last night did
you think
um this will quickly fade from our
memories that this won't be enormously
significant in terms of the course of
the war I don't think it will fade but I
think what the Secretary General has
done is very important he's obviously
said that the investigation is ongoing
but instead of waiting for it to
conclude he's been very quick to point
out certain issues uh surrounding the
incident and really reconfirming that it
was most likely a Ukrainian missile that
was fired to try and interdict a Russian
missile saying that it was not a
deliberate attack and fundamentally it
doesn't change a threat to Nato in the
East so I think that sort of calming
measure and I absolutely agree with Adam
I mean the defense and deterrence it's
NATO's bread and butter so they are well
tuned to escalation management so how do
you think that they might respond
well I think first it's it's always good
to review posture
um and they are have continued to review
posture since uh the major Summit in
June
um so to check about this sort of
Defense lay down in the East but
actually I also think this is an
opportunity to open a dialogue with
Russia because Russia will be very
spooked by this incident as well and
will not want a reoccurrence and at the
moment there's very few communication
channels so it's something that you
could use as a confidence building
measure to start to get NATO and Russia
to talk a little bit more and try and
prevent these types of things happening
again but I suppose they can take some
uh heart from the fact that the initial
reaction when it did happen was one of
dialogue and and one of Let's just find
out what's happening rather than
International Panic exactly that's
heartening also the fact that of 100
cruise missiles reportedly fired by
Russia yesterday 73 of them were
successfully interdicted so that tells
you that and this is higher than it has
been in a couple of weeks so a defense
over you crane is improving and also
we're still getting reports that these
types of Munitions are in short supply
from Russia so actually this this
incident might not
um happen again for quite some time
so back to what else is happening on the
ground what what's been happening uh in
those areas that we've been looking at
over the last few weeks aside from the
Polish Ukrainian border well the main
point of this week is the liberation of
Curson which took around four months in
the South uh what's significant at the
moment is we're still getting reports
that Ukrainian forces are trying to
cross the NEPA river move to the South
essentially to try and either right
flank Russian forces which are now
having to move their defenses to prepare
for that but also to try and push
Russian Artillery range out of range of
curse on which will then protect curse
on City itself and the big question
Still Remains whether Ukraine are going
to push on with this counter-offensive
over the winter or use it as a pause and
sort of a recuperation period for more
deliberate operations after the spring
okay Ed Arnold from Ruthie good to talk
to you thanks very much